SpongeBob SquarePants has no shortage of
inappropriate jokes but that's what
makes this show so hilarious oddly
enough some scenes redeemed a little too
extra for kids which is why they were
banned in other countries he won't
believe which deleted scenes never made
it across the border keep watching to
find out Help Wanted it's no secret that
some SpongeBob SquarePants scenes are a
little out there so it comes as no
surprise that some countries see fit to
cut out some temperamental scenes but we
never once thought that the first-ever
episode would have a deleted moment
season 1 episode 1 goes by the name of
Help Wanted
and it basically introduces all of the
characters to the viewers this is a very
special episode because well it's
SpongeBob's first day at the Krusty Krab
problem is mr. Krabs and Squidward
aren't so sure that spongebob is ready
for the job so instead of crushing his
spirits mr. Krabs tells SpongeBob that
he can apply for the job as long as he
locates a hydrodynamic spatula while
spongebob is away a convoy of buses
containing hundreds of hungry anchovies
park in front of the Krusty Krab
and start pouring in mr. Krabs and
Squidward are terrified the anchovies
are out of control and they simply can't
make enough Krabby Patties to feed them
all that's when spongebob bursts in
hydrodynamic spatula and hands he makes
hundreds of Krabby Patties and
majestically feeds the anchovies while
Tiny Tim's living in a sunlight loving
in the moonlight plays in the background
and believe it or not but this scene was
deleted in Italy for unknown reasons
while some people believe that Italy
didn't want to broadcast a Tiny Tim song
on a kids show this has yet to be proven
jellyfishing while many of us were
shocked to find out that Italy banned
this hilarious scene we weren't exactly
surprised at Poland deleted this next
one in season 1 episode 3 a there's a
very graphic scene between Patrick and
Squidward that automatically sounded
poland's alarms jellyfishing is a funny
episode that goes on to show just how
clueless spongebob and patrick really
are at the beginning of the up
the two pals are watching jellyfish from
afar they decide to put their jellyfish
nuts together and go jellyfishing on
their way home they cross paths with
Squidward who's in the process of taking
a bike ride they ask him if he wants to
join but he says he's too busy soon
after a jellyfish gets stuck in
Squidward's wheel causing him to get
into a severe accident next time we see
him he's bandaged from head to toe and
sitting in a wheelchair so when
spongebob and patrick see him again they
decide that Squidward needs a best day
ever to boost his morale we're gonna
make this your best day they take him
jellyfishing but there's a problem
Squidward can't use his hands to hold
the Nets because well he's wearing a
full-body cast so after a few failed
attempts Patrick forces the net through
Squidward's cast out so yeah this scene
was deleted in early polish versions
after being deemed too violent hooky
there's a reason why some TV shows make
it a point to say don't try this at home
and well it's because some children have
a hard time recognizing dangerous
scenarios for this reason most cartoon
stress safety and refrain from covering
terminal scenarios but we can probably
all agree that SpongeBob SquarePants
isn't like most cartoons in season 1
episode 20 a Patrick shows up at
SpongeBob's work and convinces him to go
to a carnival but to SpongeBob's horror
the carnival turns out to be the hooks
that mr. Krabs just finished warning him
about the ginger worse what could be
worse than that gift shops
despite telling Patrick that the hooks
are dangerous
the starfish continues to eat cheese off
of them and even sits on a particularly
pointy one now that's got to hurt but at
some point Patrick sticks a dozen hooks
into his mouth and starts joking around
what he's doing is super dangerous which
is why polish UK and Norwegian earrings
admitted this scene all together these
countries didn't want to promote
reckless behavior to young groups of
children they were afraid that kids
would try to mimic Patrick's insanely
dangerous actions so they deleted the
scene in earlier versions of the episode
what do you guys think did Patrick take
things too far by playing hooky just one
bite in season three episode 43 a we
find out that Squidward has never eaten
the krabby patty before
spongebob is shocked he tries to
convince Squidward to take a bite out of
a krabby patty
however spongebob continues to edge him
on until finally Squidward takes a bite
he tells spongebob if they taste awful
but he's actually lying when spongebob
leaves Squidward eats the rest of the
krabby patty out of the trash and
desperately tries to eat more of them
without being seen unfortunately
spongebob keeps getting in his way so
we're desperate Squidward tries to sneak
into the Krusty Krab at night to feast
on as many Krabby Patties as possible
the first version of this episode aired
a scene that was later taken out of
every single version in this scene we
see Squidward sneaking into the Krusty
Krab and triggering and alarmed a bucket
of gasoline falls on Squidward's feet
and a match is thrown into the equation
Squidward gets blown up and then suffers
another explosions shortly after despite
this scene being creative and funny most
countries didn't want to show it to
their youth so the episode was revised
and altered accordingly in the end the
scene was deemed too violence for
children were me we totally understand
why Squidward's explosion scene was cut
out of the original episode however we
can't say the same for the wormy song in
season 2 episode 25 a Patrick and
SpongeBob our task who's watching over
Sandy's pets while she's out of town one
of Sandy's pets is a monarch caterpillar
named wormy
gggg they play hide and seek with wormy
and literally have the best day ever
heck they even dance around and laugh
together for hours during this montage a
song called that's what friends do is
played in the background
[Music]
yet for some reason the entire song was
cut from the Italian version of the
episode their decision to cut out this
heartwarming and non vulgar song raised
a lot of eyebrows especially since Italy
didn't give a valid reason for cutting
out the friendly scene since the song is
in English it makes sense that some
countries wouldn't want it playing in
the background
however Italy chose to cut this epic
scene up all together why do you guys
think that the that's what friends do
song was taken out of the Italian
version let us know in the comments
section naughty nautical neighbors there
seems to be a trend going on here one
that places Squidward in a heap of
life-threatening scenarios it's safe to
say that Squidward is clumsy beyond
belief we mean common he's been hurt
more times than we can count in season 1
episode 4 eh Squidward bakes himself a
delicious souffle he's so excited to eat
it but once again his pesky neighbors
are ruining his alone time Squidward can
hear SpongeBob and Patrick laughing
their butts off outside Squidward just
wants to eat a souffle in peace so he
decides to break the pals up he blows a
mean messages into jelly balloons and
sends them their way and soon the BFFs
start to fight Squidward is having a
great time watching his neighbours
bicker so he goes outside to enjoy his
souffle on a lawn chair Squidward is
laughing so profusely that he starts
choking over his fort he literally
swallows it whole and he gets jammed in
his throat now if that isn't karma we
don't know what is it's easy to see why
Poland wanted this scene cut out after
all it literally showcases someone
gasping for breath and passing out if
you think this scene was bad your jaw or
literally hit the floor when we reveal
number one on this list band geeks
here's another deleted scene that just
may shock you do you guys remember the
episode of band geeks it's only one of
the most epic spongebob squarepants
episodes of all time season two episode
35 B is all about Squidward's old
schoolmate squilliam and how he offers
good word to play at the bubble bowl
squidward doesn't have a band and school
ium knows it so to prove him wrong
Squidward asked the people of Bikini
Bottom to join him on stage despite
having one of the worst fans in the
ocean Squidward starts to conduct and lo
and behold his band is amazing the crowd
goes wild when the band performs a song
sweet victory
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a total hit and arguably one of the
best scenes the episode has to offer
oddly enough this entire scene was cut
from persian and italian dubs
we totally understand why violent and
inappropriate scenes get cut from time
to time but we have no idea why sweet
victory wasn't broadcasted in iran or
italy their viewers totally missed out
on the most epic performance ever
jellyfish jam in season 1 episode 7 bee
we find out that spongebob has a
deep-rooted love for jellyfish by now
it's no secret that spongebob likes to
spend a lot of his free time
gallivanting through the jellyfish
fields one day a jellyfish follows
spongebob home and they bump into
Squidward along the way but spongebob
doesn't pay him any mind he's ready to
party it up jellyfish style for the next
12 hours
spongebob and his new friends dance to
techno rave music and have the time of
their lives
however this entire scene never made it
across the Polish border it turned out
that Poland was concerned that the
techno scene could potentially cause
harm to children suffering from epilepsy
and since this scene was jam-packed with
flashing lights and stroboscopic effects
we totally get where they're coming from
still it's a shame that this team was
cut from polish airings because well
it's downright hilarious
[Music]
SpongeBob SquarePants versus the big one
in season 6 episode 11 the Krusty Krab
is making little snow business because
of how it is hot outside so mr. Krab
decides to move his business to the
middle of the sea unfortunately for him
Patrick tags along and foils mr. Krabs
money-making plans
Squidward spongebob mr. Krabs sandy and
Patrick get separated by a huge wave and
spend the rest of the episode trying to
get back to bikini bottom
Squidward SpongeBob and Patrick end up
on an island with daredevil surfers they
tell them that to get home they must
surf the big one which is a gigantic
wave that only occurs once in a blue
moon the episode is called spongebob
versus the big one in North America but
some countries don't want to put the big
one on their title card so Poland
changed the title - spongebob versus the
big wave Wow
Latvia Ukraine Australia and Germany
changed it - the secret of Kahuna Laguna
out of the picture we weren't kidding
when we said that the last deleted scene
on this list was going to make your jaw
drop in Episode two 14b Squidward
attempts to sell his paintings at the
Krusty Krab unfortunately they're not
very good and customers are getting
super annoyed mr. Krab wants to shut the
whole thing down
however he changes his tune when an art
appraiser tells him and since mr. Krabs
loves making money more than anything he
considers taking Squidward out of the
picture to rock in some serious dough
this entire scene was cut from the UK
version and we can't really blame them
for choosing to forgo the scene after
all it gets graphic real fast shame on
you mr. Krabs the life of your employee
is worth more than all of the money in
the ocean combined so which one of these
deleted scenes did you find the most
shocking let us know in the comment
section and that's the end of our video
as usual
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe to the things thanks for
watching we'll see you soon
[Music]